[Music]
clay's in austin texas hey clay how are
you
good how are you dave better than i
deserve what's up
um my wife and i are thinking about
downsizing into an rv
selling our house and down closing into
an rv we did this before we had kids and
now we have kiddos
and we're kind of wondering if it's a
good idea i mean
i know the market's hot right now to
sell our house so we'll make some money
on it and
probably get out of bed i haven't put
complete in the paper
because i don't know what we're actually
going to make on it how many kids and
how old are you
i've got two kids they're four and six
okay and your motivation for doing this
is
what getting you out of debt
no don't do it no no
two reasons four and six
in an rv
reason number three yeah rvs
our fees go down there's two reasons rv
goes down
in value no no we already have the rv
oh it still goes down in value yeah
now you don't own any appreciating
assets you only own depreciating assets
okay is the rv paid for
yes what do you owe on it i'm sorry
what's it worth
what's it worth what's it worth what's
it worth about
about 15 000. okay cool all right and
what's your household income
about 55 depending on overtime
good for you okay well much like our
last caller i love the motivation to be
debt-free i'm with you on that
i'm not willing to pay the price that
you're willing to pay
i love my grandbabies the idea of being
stuck with two of them in an rv
for the rest of my life until they grow
up is
suicidal for me i just couldn't do it
one of us one of us would die
we're trying to move to a different city
and do it that way okay
for how long how long are you going to
be in the rv uh
we're expecting two years max maybe
three yeah i i
you can do whatever you want to do
you're a grown up you called and asked
me what i would do
i personally could not do that would not
do that
i don't think the financials are that
great on what you're talking about i
don't think it's like a big windfall
and the lifestyle of it i just couldn't
do i mean i've got friends at rv
i got friends that have i can think of
one right now has got three kids and
they are
it's their adventure they live
everywhere and they do it on purpose but
they're not doing it so they can get out
of debt they're doing it because they
love being on the road you know that
kind of stuff but i
would the ramses have done that when we
were on our get out of debt journey
the answer is there wouldn't be any
ramses if we had done that